we're told that figure a is a scale
image of figure b so that's figure a
this is figure b here the scale that
maps figure a to figure b is one
to two and one half
what is the value of x
all right pause this video and see if
you can figure it out
all right so x is the length of this
side right over here in on figure a and
the corresponding side on figure b has
length five
and so one way to think about it is the
ratio between x and five should be
one to two and a half because that's the
scale that goes from figure a to figure
b figure a to figure b
so the ratio let me write this out
the ratio between x
and 5
so the ratio of x
to 5
this should be an equivalent ratio as
one
two
two and a half
one to two
and a half and that one is hard to read
let me make a deeper blue there you go
all right so let's just think about how
to do this to go from
two and a half
to five
to go that way you would multiply by two
so to go from one to x you would also
multiply by two so the value of x is
equal to two if these are scaled up you
multiply this by two and a half you get
to five so the scale factor is one to
two and a half let's do another example
we're told figure a is a scale image of
figure b and we see them both right over
here
and once again we need to figure out
what x is going to be and they don't
give us the scale factor but we can
figure out the scale factor how do we do
that well we can see when you go from
course this is this side right over here
corresponds to this side
it's the shorter side that forms a right
angle with the base this is the longer
side that forms a right angle with the
base
and so you could set up some ratios you
could say look the ratio of 3 to 4
you could say the ratio
of 3
to 4
let me do that blue color the ratio of 3
to 4 is going to be the same thing as
the ratio of x to 7.2
the ratio of x
to 7.2
x
to
7.2
and so how do we figure out what x is
going to be
well how do you go from 4 to 7.2 what do
you have to multiply by you might want
to get out a calculator or you might be
able to do this in your head 4 72 is 2
times 36 which is 2 times 18 so 4 times
18 would be 72 or 4 times 1.8 would be
7.2 and if you don't feel good about
that mental arithmetic you could just
do the division 4 goes into 7 one time 1
times 4 is 4 subtract you get a 3 you're
gonna have your decimal right over there
bring down the two thirty two four goes
into 32 eight times eight times four is
32 and we're done so to go from four to
seven point two you have to multiply by
one point eight and so to go from three
to x you also have to multiply by 1.8
and so x is 3 times 1.8 what is that
going to be well 3 times 18 is what 30
it's 54. so this is going to be 5
let me verify that or show you that 18
or 1.8 times 3 3 times 8 is 24 3 times
1 is 3 plus 2 is 5 one number behind the
decimal point 5.4 and we're done